as I mentioned earlier there's only
about 200 250 people who get through all
four levels so maybe just talk a little
bit about like it is a Somali a and then
how that process works yeah so you know
in the to generalize sommelier is just a
person in a restaurant who helps you out
with your wine selections normally that
person also is probably running the wine
program in the restaurant so they're you
know building out the wine list they're
making the selections they're the ones
dealing with the distributors and buying
wine it's kind of like a little business
within the business and you know then
they're on the floor at night helping
guests make selections and selling wine
you know I think the the word sommelier
has kind of expanded since when I first
started doing it to mean a lot of
different things like a lot of people in
distribution or people who are teachers
in wine or even like certain people who
work on the one of production side will
call them so sommeliers in my night and
there's an argument in the industry
about like what is the sommelier would
exactly that that term mean but in my
mind it's always been a position in a
restaurant where you're helping guess
with with wine selections now the master
sommelier title is a is a distinction
and a credit a credit that's like earned
through going this through this series
of examinations so it's a little bit
different it's not it's a title it's not
a position in a restaurant like the word
some what it is and to earn that title
you go through these different levels so
level one is basically a very
introductory test where you go and for
like two days you're you know you you
take like a wine course and at the end
of course you take a written exam and
it's like 80 multiple-choice questions
and either pass where you go pretty
straightforward the pass rates really
high if you know anything about wine
going into it you could probably do
pretty well and people from all
different industries will go take this
test just to learn a little bit more
it's really interesting level to you
once you pass that level one you're
allowed to take level two is more to
there's it gets broken into three pieces
that the service piece was a tasting
piece and there's a the theory or kind
of like the written examination part
it's definitely harder you probably need
a little bit of restaurant experience to
be able to get through it you need to
have been blind tasting and like
learning how to blind taste a little bit
in order to to get through it it's still
quite basic but it's definitely much
harder than the first exam so the the
rate of the pass rate goes from caught
like 90 or 95 percent at level one down
to about fifty percent for level two but
let's say you get through it then you're
entitled to go for level three which is
called the advanced exam and the
advanced exam is the same three parts
there's Theory there service there's
tasting but you know again a much higher
level of difficulty there's more to the
blind tasting there's a lot more to the
service exam the level of questioning
for theory is much deeper this is kind
of like really what separates is the
biggest jump is what separates kind of
like the real pros from you know maybe
an enthusiastic consumer for instance
the pass rate for that is usually
somewhere in the vicinity but I call it
twenty to thirty percent most years and
then once you've passed that and all you
know a lot of people will take that
several times I took it a couple of
times before I got through once you're
through that then you have to wait to be
invited to take the master's exam so
that's level four and it's basically the
exact same tests as the advanced exam
and in a sense how its setup same number
of wines that you blind taste the same
three sections but again the level of
difficulty of questioning goes up the
intricacy of service that you need to
perform goes up and the wines that they
pour you for the blind tasting get a
little bit more difficult and you have
to score in to pass you have to score at
a higher rate so it's quite difficult
and that the pass rate drops down to
somewhere but
10% some years it's like 3% some years
it's 5 some years it's a little bit more
than that but if you get a 10 percent
pass rate that's pretty that's really
strong you know and a lot of people
never get through I know a lot of people
in my industry who've taken it numerous
times and never get through and the
thing is you can only take it once a
year so there's a lot of people who have
been in the program you know usually by
the time you even get to that level
you've put in years of your life to
begin with and then I know some people
have taken the master's exam a dozen
times you know or close to a dozen times
it's just an enormous amount of your
time and energy that goes into it
so it's it's a very difficult test so I
knew nothing about wine in general I
would literally embarrass myself if I
try to pronounce 99% of wines and I
think we were at dinner once and you or
somebody else brought up this
documentary
ssam which you were featured in and so
of course I went home and Flynn and I
watched it and I was blown away at one
the fact that you subjected yourself to
this but to just learning about how
intense it is right so for those that
don't know you should one definitely go
watch documentary but two it's it's
things like the blind test right that
most people here that know like oh okay
so what you just closed your eyes and
you taste a wine but it's not just like
hey is this red or white it's literally
where is the wine from what year is it
what type of wine what are the
ingredients like like the level of
understanding and really expertise you
have to have is pretty compelling I mean
it blew my mind
to the point where my favorite part of
the documentary is like somebody's
tasting wine and they're describing it
as like a new can of tennis balls or it
tastes like or smells like cat piss and
like and you're kind of like wait a
minute this is such a grain or
understanding of wine the different wine
regions and periods of time etc that the
study period like how long did you study
to actually pass that cuz it's not like
you just study for three weeks show up
and like cross your fingers
hope you pass right no no the so the
total amount of time for me from when I
took my introductory test that first
level until I passed my MS was about
five years which you know there's people
who have passed who have gone through it
much like not much quicker than that but
a little quicker than that it's
relatively fast though there's I would
say the average has got to be somewhere
in like seven to nine year range for I
think a lot of people so it's a
significant amount of time and you know
leading up to the exam I mean you're
studying probably a year out if not like
you know probably at least eight months
if you're if you're not studying by six
months out and prepping you're you're
behind it's just an enormous amount of
information to prepare for and you know
the blind tasting piece of it is really
difficult like getting to the point
where you can identify grape varieties
and you know where something's coming
from and you know picking the right
vintages and things like that for the
wines it it sounds like it's one of
these things that you need to be like an
innate taster for but it's not
necessarily that it's just a [ __ ] ton of
practice and really understanding and
doing it over and over and over and over
again so it's a lot